He's going to expand on this. He's going
to say, "All right, however,
you cannot go to a temple and partake of
their sacrifices and their worship of
the gods and goddesses." Why? Though we
know an idol is nothing. He said it
right here. But there are demons, Satan
demons, attached to those idols who will
appear as the gods and goddesses of
idols to ensnare you to their control
and dominion. And I don't want you to
come under their control. and their
influence.
See?
So now let's see what he says
now the complete picture. Right
now the complete picture right
below Caesar. All you guys don't be
tired. I'm the one tired with a
headache.
What do I mean then? 1 Corinthians
10:19-34 that a thing sacrificed to
idols is anything or that an idol is
anything. Remember he just said no no
but I say that the things which the
Gentiles sacrifice they sacrifice demons
not to God. Now that's the danger.
There is no Zeus or Bal or
Artimus or Jupiter. Jupiter is another
name for Zeus. Bal is another name for
Zeus.
But what there are are demons and Satan.
And that's what I fear that if you go to
the temples as they're sacrificing the
gods, by being there, you're going to
open yourself to demonic oppression,
infestation.
Love you guys. May the Lord Jesus
preserve his people in Israel,
preserve you, fill you with the spirit
to love Jesus Christ more than politics
and love your Palestinian brothers,
sisters, and Jesus equally and that
you're all one in Christ.
All right.
Now, watch how deep this gets and how
beautiful the Bible is. The Bible is
supernatural, guys, if it's unpacked
correctly.
I do not want you to become sharers and
demons. You cannot drink the cup of the
Lord and the cup of demons. You cannot
partake of the table of the Lord and the
table demons. Or do we provoke the Lord
to jealousy? Are we stronger than he?
Okay. Now,
now he fleshes out
eating sacrifices to idols. All things
are lawful but not all things are
profitable. Meaning God has made lawful
all eating of meats. Okay?
You can eat whatever you want. So much
for the sabotarians, right? Trying to
bring us back under the yoke of the Old
Testament.
Let no one seek his own good but that of
the other person. See, this is it. Love.
Eat anything that's sold in the meat
market without asking questions for
conscience sake. Ah, that answers the
question. What about halal meat? Eat
anything sold in the markets.
Now, preferably go to non-Muslim
markets. Preferably, you don't go to a
Muslim market. Go to Christians. Support
Christians. Give your money to
Christians.
However, if you don't have Christian
markets and you like, for example,
cheese, Lebna, right, white cheese and
all that, you don't get that in the
American markets. You can only only get
it at an Arab store or a Muslim store.
You guys know what I'm talking about.
PA, fresh pira, Lebna, right? Whatever
it is.
And these are run by Muslims. You know
what I'm talking about. These are run by
Muslims.
Paul says, "Go buy whatever you want
from these markets." Why? For the earth
is the Lord's as well as its fullness.
Everything in the earth belongs to the
Lord Jesus, not to Allah. All those
animals they sacrifice to Allah. Allah
has nothing to do with those animals
because Allah of the Quran is not God,
Satan. Those animals belong to the Lord
Jesus Christ whether the person realizes
it or not. But you know it belongs to
Jesus. So whatever belongs to Christ is
yours. Buy it. Bless the name of Christ
and it's yours.
See that teaching.
So that answer the question that I get
asked millions of times. Sal
cuz you who are Middle Eastern or
whatever you know you like to have
Turkish cafe or you like to have Lebna,
you like to go get go cheese, right?
Delicious. Or get fresh pa,
Middle Eastern bread. And these are only
found in these Middle Eastern shops,
right? So what do I do there? A Muslim
owns it.
Zetun olives, right? What do I do? What
do I do?
You got it.
They're owned by Muslims. Paul told you.
Here it is. Here's the answer. Eat
anything that is sold in the meat
market. Now, at Corenth, the meat
markets were run by
pagans. And some of the meat they sold
were meat sacrificed to the gods. But
look what he says, though.
Buy it but don't ask. What does it mean?
Don't ask did you say over this meat
before you sacrificed? Don't ask. Buy it
and go. So don't ask them hey this meat
did you sacrifice it to Zeus? Don't ask
why. Why don't you ask?
Because if you ask and they say yes and
you buy it, you know what you did? You
just Amen. They're sacrificing, I'm okay
with you sacrificing to false gods.
You understand what Paul is saying?
If you ask and they tell you, then you
can't buy.
Why? Because if you go ahead and buy it,
you just told the man what you're doing
is good and pleasing in the sight of my
God. It's okay. desacus.
It's all good. You're all right.
Do you understand the principle? So
don't ask.
If one of the unbelievers invites you
and you want to go eat anything that is
set before you without asking questions
for conscience sake because this is what
I'm also well my family they're Muslim
and I'm going to eat halal food. What
did Paul say? Go.
Go. But don't ask whether you pronounce
over the food.
Don't ask.
See, for conscience, whose conscience?
Let's see. But if anyone says to you,
this is this is meat co idols. Do not
eat it. See, that's when you say sorry,
I can't for the sake of the one who
informed you and for conscience sake.
Now you say I can't eat it. Now you be a
witness. Now you be light of the world,
salt of the earth. Now that door opened
where you now preach why you can't eat
the meat to their god because it's not
God.
I do not mean your own conscience. Your
conscience is clear because you know
their god is not God and the meat
belongs to Jesus.
For why is my freedom judged by
another's conscience? If I partake with
gratefulness, why am I slandered
considering that for which I give
thanks? In other words, don't let your
freedom to eat anything be used
against you to condemn you or to be used
by God to rebuke you for misusing your
freedom. Because if my freedom is being
used to cause people stumble, the Lord
will rebuke me. Okay. Now, do we
understand the principle here?
Do we understand the principle?
When do you not eat? When they tell you
it's sacrificed to Allah. That means you
can't go to their Eid,
right?
Is it?
I even forgot the name for when they
break their fast during Ramadan.
Ifar, right? Ifar. It'sar, right, man?
That means during Ramadan.
Let me see.
Ifar. Ifar. Okay, I thought it's ifar.
Anyway, maybe it's pronounced
differently. Nonetheless, during
Ramadan, you can't go and break fast
with them. And at the end of the month
of Ramadan, you can't go celebrate Eid
with them because, you know, they're now
doing it as celebration for their God.
And if they ask you why, because they
don't believe all of the Quran is God.
Oh, really? Now you're going to get an
opportunity to witness.
Whether then you eat or drink or
whatever you do, do all to the glory of
God. Give no offense either to Jews or
to Greeks or the church of God. Avoid
unnecessary
stumbling blocks as much as you can.
Just as I also please all men all
things, not seeking my own prophet, but
the profit of many so that they may be
saved. Now, do you understand what the
context of these
Yeah. Are you sure, man? I'm gonna have
to check. Anyway, I believe you.
All right, everyone got it? No, my thing
is slow.
Ifar. Yep, it is. You're right. Sorry,
because I I got a brain freeze.
Okay, did everyone understand now the
context of these passages? It's not
about the trinity in 1 Corinthians 8
where Paul fleshes out in 1 Corinthians
10.
It's about sacrif. So what did he say?
Do not eat sacrifices to idols in their
temples.
Don't go to their temples and partake of
their sacrifices. But if those
sacrifices are sold in the meat market,
buy them. Bless them in the name of Lord
Jesus Christ. Eat. Or if you have a
relative who's not a Christian, who
invites you, gives you food,
but doesn't tell you this meat was for a
god that they're now serving, eat. But
if they say this was a sacrifice, don't
eat. To be a witness to that person,
lest you justify in his mind or her mind
it's okay to worship their gods.
Question answer. now
if okay good California
thank you question answered
so now do you know why he mentioned one
god the father one lord Jesus Christ
does anyone know why what the context is
there
what's the context there what's the
context of him saying meaning these
gods, goddesses don't exist. The idols
are nothing.
We know that because we know there's
only one God, the father, one Lord Jesus
Christ. We know these idols are nothing.
We know their gods don't exist.
They don't know that. That's the
context.
Now, with that said,
with that said, let's come back here.